lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
practicar la representación de algunas
fracciones que se van a encontrar muy
seguido la primera fracción que vamos a
explorar es un quinto
y después veremos un cuarto
y por último exploraremos un medio
comencemos con un quinto los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y traten de pensar
como representarían esta fracción en
decimales hay varias maneras en las que
podemos pensar en esto pueden dividir 1
entre 5 podemos decir que esto es igual
a 1 entre 5 y si lo hicieran obtendrían
la respuesta correcta pero hay una
manera mucho más sencilla de pensar en
esto una forma de pensar en esto es
preguntarnos cómo podemos representar
este número en decimos ya que si
conocemos la cantidad de décimos
podremos representar este número como
decimal para pasar de quintos a décimos
tenemos que multiplicar denominador por
dos así que multiplicamos también el
numerador por 2
un quinto uno por dos es dos tenemos dos
décimos y sabemos cómo representar esto
en notación decimal esto es 0.2 esto
está en el lugar de las décimas por lo
que tenemos exactamente dos décimas
ahora analicemos un cuarto y es la misma
idea cómo puedo representar esto como
decimal primero podemos preguntarnos si
esto no podemos representar cierta
cantidad de décimos pero no es tan
sencillo porque 10 no es múltiplo de 4
así que veamos si podemos hacerlo en
términos de centésimos ya que 100 es
múltiplo de 4 para pasar de 4 a 100
tenemos que multiplicar por 25 así que
multiplicamos denominador y numerador
por 25 para así obtener una fracción
equivalente 1 por 25 es 25 y ya vimos
que 4 por 25 es 100 así que un cuarto es
igual a 25 centésimas y podemos
representar esto en notación decimal
como 0.25 que también podemos decir son
décimas y cinco centésimas ahora veamos
un medio y aplicamos la misma idea 10 es
múltiplo de 2 así que podemos pensar en
esto en términos de decimos para pasar
de 2 a 10 multiplicamos por 5 así que
también multiplicamos el numerador por 5
así que un medio es igual a 5 decimos
que si queremos representar como decimal
será 0.5 5 décimas porque es importante
esto bueno en primer lugar se darán
cuenta que estas fracciones se las van a
encontrar muy seguido en la vida y
pueden verlo en ambos sentidos si
ustedes se encuentran un 0.22 décimas o
20 centésimas se darán cuenta
inmediatamente de que esto es igual a un
quinto o 25 centésimas es igual a un
cuarto y un medio es igual a 0.5 y
viceversa y esto no es útil solamente
para estas tres fracciones también nos
va a servir para múltiplos de estas
fracciones por ejemplo si alguien les
pregunta a ver rápidamente a cuántos
decimales es igual tres puntos
bueno mentalmente podemos decir ok tres
quintos es igual a tres por un quinto y
sabemos que un quinto es punto dos dos
décimas así que esto es igual a tres por
dos décimas que es igual a seis décimas
0.6 así que rápidamente encontraron la
respuesta al recordar esto y también
pueden hacerlo al revés pueden decir que
seis décimas es igual a tres por punto
dos tres por dos décimas y sabemos que
dos décimas es un quinto así que esto es
igual a tres por un quinto y esto es
algo con lo que se van a familiarizar
mientras más lo practiquen ahora digamos
que quieren
como fracción 0.75 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo ustedes mismos
pueden darse cuenta que 75 es tres veces
25 así que punto 75 es igual a 3 por 25
centésimas y sabemos que 25 centésimas
es igual a un cuarto así que esto es
igual a 3 por un cuarto que es igual a
tres cuartos y conforme ustedes
practiquen esto no tendrán que hacer
todo este desarrollo mentalmente
directamente van a reconocer que punto
75 es igual a tres cuartos porque punto
25 es igual a un cuarto ahora digamos
que tenemos 2.5 y queremos representar
esto como una fracción hay varias formas
en las que podemos representar esto
podemos decir que 2.5 es igual a 5 por
punto 5 que va a ser igual a 5 por un
medio que es igual a 5 medios es una
fracción impropia pero sigue siendo una
fracción y el objetivo aquí es que
aunque ustedes ya estén familiarizados
con alguna forma de transformar
fracciones a decimales y viceversa si
ustedes reconocen inmediatamente
un quinto un cuarto un medio puede su
representación decimal podrían resolver
operaciones de manera más rápida vean
que si lo hacemos de la forma contraria
vamos a tener que trabajar más por
ejemplo vamos a convertir tres quintos a
decimales pues tengo que dividir tres
entre 55 va a dividir a 3 y cuántas
veces cabe cinco en tres pues tengo que
poner el punto decimal me queda un 35
cabe en 30 6 veces 6 por 5 es 30 30
menos 30 es 0 es una división exacta y
eso no fue tan difícil de hacer pero si
lo hacemos de esta otra manera va a ser
mucho más rápido y a mí me gusta esta
otra manera no sólo porque es más rápida
sino porque también nos da cierta
intuición sobre lo que está pasando
realmente aquí